I like it best when there's just a
little crystal of an idea that comes
from somewhere I know not where and it
just sort of springs forth little tiny
idea you know can be a line or an image
or just something that a character would
say and ideally when it works best it's
it's a it's a thing that that occurs to
me and then I immediately know
everything about that character it's a
it's a little nugget of a thing that
makes me completely understand who this
person is and then it's just sort of
then it just sort of comes out and it's
very easy it's rarely like that however
more more often I have to really
kickstart that process at any number of
points so I might sit around with a
guitar and just play and play and play
and play
you know noodling until I come up with a
musical idea that I like and I'll play
the musical idea over and over again and
sort of hum nonsense syllables against
it until I hear a word that I think
works and maybe that word becomes
something you know I know I know this
line ends with the word dissolve and so
what rhymes with dissolve and then we'll
look at that be about and you know along
the way you have to sort of keep
stepping back and looking at it and
seeing if it makes sense and thinking
about where you want it to take the
listener and and just sort of piece by
piece by piece stringing it together
until it's a until it's the thing that
you that you believe it should be
real I'm a real sucker for the the slow
sad sensitive folk II stuff I really am
it's one of the reasons that I love
bluegrass I came to listen to bluegrass
relatively recently but it's it's it's
one of the few styles of music that
actually can move me to tears when I'm
listening to it
you know there's some of the sadder
bluegrass songs are so amazingly
powerful have such an emotional quality
to them even though the music is very
simple and the the messages are very
simple it's always it's always there's
always a child dying or somebody's
mother is dying or it's somebody just
missing their family who's far away this
is very simple concepts but they
something about something about the
simplicity of the music and the
simplicity of the ideas just expressed
in this really raw way really really
hits me and so you know I try I try when
I can to you know I am a lot of the time
I am writing funny songs but I try to
bring out that emotional aspect of it
when I can so you know I try to find
sympathy for the characters that I'm
writing about even if they're ridiculous
which frequently they are I like to
think well what you know what do they
want and and and more important what is
it that they want that they're not
getting it that they're never going to
get and why is that sad to them you know
that's that's to me the heart of writing
a good song is getting to that getting
to that piece of it
there's a I can't think of the name of
the song now but it's a Stanley it's a
Stanley Brothers song and it might it
might be called my precious children or
something like that but it's it's
literally it's he's talking about how
his his kit his kids have sort of grown
up and moved away and it used to be the
family was together all the time and now
they're dispersed and he rarely rarely
sees them and it's a kid a little
just picky about it and maybe it's
because I have a parent now that that
that means so much to me but that's
that's that's the one that you know I
was driving somewhere in the car and
that song came on and I started weeping
you know it's really really amazing